peu
[Musique]
oui la sopie la vie de nos maîtres pour
ce moment de bonheur à l'épuisement
c'est pas demain j'aime bien le café aux
bourgeois ils peuvent sortir de table
mini surprendra les filles tu as qu'il
nous surprenne une première voilà une
bouteille de vin et moi si la pâte et
que j'ai sauvée du dîner pour qu'il vous
en reste du pâté je n'ai pas passé
elle n'a pas repassé à sa fille voilà
comme je comprends l'amour être aimé
pour soi même comme perez les bourgeois
ne sortons pas mis non vous n'aurez pas
à clé alors dès que tout sera éteint
vous passerez par cette fenêtre jaurès -
de la laisse entrouverte montré jusqu'à
ma chambre
non mais en tout bien tout honneur
naturellement y viennent d'écarter ces
jeunes égarés
non
mais ce mois tu m'ennuie oui eh bien moi
je désire que ça ne se renouvelle pas d
équipe et par m tu le désires vraiment
parfaitement
laissez-nous sa fille non ma parole
d'honneur
tu as bien d' accès de folie aujourd'hui
en face un sens c'est toi une femme
comme il faut venir faire cet esclandre
en plein conseil d'administration et
qu'est-ce qui me prouvait que tu étais
en conseil d'administration mais comment
ce qu'ils pouvaient je t'avais dis je
vais à la réunion du conseil
d'administration du chemin de fer du
nord
non mais c'était clair il me sente mieux
non ça ne suffit pas madame il faut en
tant qu advienne se rendre compte par
elle-même
il n'y avait pas cinq minutes que le
président avait tous vers la science que
tout à coup une tronche ça va dans la
salle du conseil c'était madame qui
s'écrit au milieu de tous les membres
épars et nous allons le voir
ça me concerne et après ils entendent
pas tous morts ces messieurs je suppose
qu'on mais tu t'es rendu absolument
ridicule et bois avec nous au je sais
bien que ça dégage pas que j'exige que
ça ne se renouvelle plus en voyant ma
parole d'honneur je ne savais plus où m
mais monsieur drop ne t'a pas vu la
figure qu'il faisait monsieur deraedt
chine
mais lille n'a pas marché va quand on
était parti vous aurez la beauté mon
cher collègue mathieu le but de prévenir
madame ribadier pour l'avenir que nos
réunions sont privés voilà ce que tu m'a
attiré et qu'est ce que tous les jeux
répond naturellement vous avez laissé
marcher sur moi mais non je t excuse et
j'ai dit que depuis quelques temps tu
donnais des signes d'aliénation mentale
vous avez dit ça non mais j'ai assuré
que le médecin ne répondait pas guérison
charmant maintenant qu'est ce que tu
aurais fait ma place et bien j'aurais
dit que j'étais venu parce que j'étais
une femme qui était parfaitement payé
pour savoir ce que valent et là la
fidélité des fêtes
parce que vous savez moi moi je n'y ai
jamais cru à votre conseil
d'administration - you tu nous as bien
russe pendant oui enfin je vous ai vu je
vous ai vue là entre hommes c'est
évident mais qu'est-ce que ça prouve que
ces salles d'assemblée sait si bien
agencé on doit être organisé pour éviter
les surprises
qu'est-ce qui me dit vous n'avez pas eu
le temps de faire filer les femmes pour
ma chère amy je t'assure vraiment que le
conseil d'administration du chemin de
fer du nord a autre chose à faire que tu
as réunir pour fois les chevaliers avec
dès le matin on vient pour cause et du
chemin de fer vous allez me faire croire
ça wallon dont il est fait pour ce main
de fer c'est plus la peine d'en parler à
nous est discuté avec une phrase est
long de ces raisonnements non ça à qui
l'on ac
de quel droit me soupçonne qu'un thé je
jamais fourni un motif de dire que
j'étais trop héros toi non mais lui lui
lui tend au lui lui est toujours temps
rabineau est-ce que c'est ma faute si
ton premier maritalement au nom c'est
bien la mienne
si j'avais été plus clair banian
obtiennent aussi c'est pour ça peut
prendre des précautions maintenant bon
le misérable quand je pense qu'il m'a
prouvé toute sa vie et que je n'y ai vu
connu notre meilleure carte de la manga
bleus avec son air de se moquer de moi
scélérat enfin même fait assez tourné au
ridicule c'est pas pour toi je te voyais
très fou parce que tu avais une femme
aveugle mais tu ne perd rien pour
attendre brda a tu m'as trompé bras tu
as eu des maîtresses et bien moi aussi
je te ferai moi aussi j'aurai des âmes
en plein et tu es tu là sentir à la
peine totale de malaria en gérer des
trompes tu oublies tu à changer de
raison sociale
il est liquidée le numéro 1 s'est pressé
la dignité oui il faudrait pas qu'elle
va trop loin l'indignation bas parce que
c'est pas lui c'est moi que tu ferais
chose c'est pas une raison parce qu'ils
étaient en route y est pour qu'on mette
en foyer qu'est ce que tu veux chaque
fois que je regarde ce tapiola de 200 la
colère qui monte au cerveau en bas on va
aller au grenier si c'est ça pourquoi
garde du parce qu'il est de bonne à
tu penses tu aimes ce n'est pas à cause
des traits de feu robineau nommer un
bonheur mais que son mari ça se garde
c'est décoratif
je te dis pas mais si ton caractère doit
s'en ressentir si la paix du ménage doit
s'en trouver menacé sa matière veux tu
que je dois d'abord à de le retoucher
modifié voyez il en ferait un seigneur
du moyen âge
donc le temps efface bien des choses et
d'acer l'éloignera non non non j'entends
le conserver comme ça il est bon que
c'est sous les yeux cet échantillon de
la fidélité conjugale
quand je ne serai que vont apprendre à
me méfier de toi quand deux mois passant
pourquoi monter parce que tu es mon mari
et moi la déraison mais c'est la
meilleure
et bien ce portrait là pour me dit
souviens toi que tous les maris sont des
imposteurs et d un très bel ouvrage où
il n'ya pas récriminer c'est inhérent à
la fonction voilà ce que dit robineau du
fond de sa toile parfaitement
et là j'entends plus regardent j'étais
bien trompé et bien dis toi bien que
tout et maritaux troppo comme ça t'es
trompé et tout est mort oui ça ne te fie
pas aux apparences plus un homme à deux
choses à se faire pardonner plus il a de
façon de les cacher de les sauver les
apparences
nos premiers taillieu dit et or elle
cherche et pis regarde et si tu ne
trouves rien dis toi que tu as mal
cherché et qu'il ya certainement quelque
chose annoncée vendredi
voilà voilà ce qu'il me dit monsieur
robineau papa la giflant qu'elle fait
moi se porta giflant qu'elle veut c'est
être ridicule une fois ce ne serait pas
de hutus moi si je le suis on ne sera
pas mal
nous nous sommes crus tu vois dans
touchant par son ton monsieur robe et
non non il ne s'agit plus de monsieur
robineau il a quitté ce monde pour un no
si tu pouvais obtenir l'extradition
ballon il a très bien où il est
mais alain si lui n'est plus là toi tu
es encore là je ne sais pas encore quand
j'entends que la leçon observe je ne
plaisante pas noro tu sais quand j'ai
décidé d'ôter l'épousé je me suis dit
autant j'étais confiante et douce avec
feu robineau autant je serai sévère et
méfiante avec son rival
comment faire ribadier je tiens la
valeur de mes matins tu avant voire vas
tu seras bien sport si tu arrives à me
trompe à tarbes le tout toujours sur mes
talons fils de file non c'est à dire que
je connais tous vos moyens toutes vos
tenues
oui j'ai le recueil que ce que ça ça
c'est la nomenclature des fredaines de
mon premier bar au sel qu'il a fait de
son vivant
naturellement le dieu il a eu le cynisme
de les consigner dans ce carnet à 5 la
postérité dans nine y aura sans doute
non il ne se contentait pas d'accompli
il fallait qu'il écrit pee wee coureurs
et archiviste à ça ça m'a donné une
fière idée de sa façon aussi clip est
d'avoir écrit tout ça il ya des choses
qui ont fait qu'on n'écrit pas c'est
cette façon d'être at war madame dans
l'eau il en a fait un recueil avec une
table des matières et al titre wii a
même un titre à il y un avis mais bateau
mais bâton petit guide pratique pour les
maris sans imagination
c'est ça ces bateaux il y en a trois
cent soixante-cinq matin c'est une
flotte à 365 autant qu'il ya deux jours
dans l'année ça qui répartis en huit ans
que notre ménage a duré nous donne à
datant tous les huit jours
oui comme la transatlantique un courrier
de madère là quand je pense que ça se
passait pour ainsi dire tous mes yeux et
quand je me suis aperçu de regard que tu
n'avais peut-être pas vu le pot
mais qu'importe maintenant grâce à ce
carnet je sais où j'en suis et vous ne
pouvez plus mabuse et de vos deux
moutures pitié je sais ce que je fais
maintenant j'aime beaucoup me rends tu
as le droit que mes mais parfaitement
vais te tiens tiens là ton conseil
d'administration ça y est attends
attends administration voilà quand je
veux faire une partie on ne se baigne ce
compagnie je dis à ma femme que j'ai une
réunion de son conseil d'administration
et bien fol est bien prêt il paraît que
quand on dit on à une réunion à son
conseil d'administration ça veut dire
qu'on va faire une partie en joyeuse
compagnie je le connais que mon cas
c'est pour shine on voit que absurde il
n'a pas le sens colmar se livrent les
vols sont communs à dassa je finirai
bien par te situes reprend au nom tu me
fatigues tu commences à du réseau nu
rejeté résonne jeu des vrais sedan ramé
parfaitement d'une rue zone
et bien je te prévoir moi si je t'ai
réseau et tu verras si tu pourra
continuer à te conduire comme tu te
contentes en moi oui toi et je saurai
tout du menton tout parce que je préfère
encore une certitude caso ce doute qui
menace tous
[Applaudissements]
et dire que je les ai épousé parce que
je voulais une femme confiante c'est la
faute à un imbécile de robin hausse et
qui me disait tout le temps ma femme
confiante jamais dit où vas-tu te vois
tu étais bah tiens là voilà la femme
confiante
donc est ce que c'est une vie sam c'est
insupportable pour un mari deux soirs
sans cesse épié surveillé
surtout au moment où il ébauche un roman
parce que voilà c'est encore toi oui
j'aime j'aime j'ai eu tort oui je te
demande pardon à quoi ça sert de
pardonner turcomans cinq minutes après
comme une enfant mais nous on sait pas
si c'est sérieux
non mais je sais bien tu me dises à
chaque fois non les les autres fois je
ne le pensais pas tandis que maintenant
il pense peut-être mais pas pour
longtemps
pour te prouver mon repentir voilà des
lettres pour toi je ne veux même dans
les villes hôtes et bien passé qu'est ce
que c'est que ces lettres mais jeunes
ribadier cercle du tout-paris ça comment
les as-tu entre les mains j'ai été les
chercher à ton cercle quand tu as été
chercher oui sachez que guy ovale et de
piles qui m'a ouvert le mont avima
envoyé chercher des lettres pour lui
vous les volumes les remettre et il me
les a données c'est trop fort des
attrape rêves va pourra mettre comme ça
mais l'être à n'importe qui merci pour
n'importe qui une femme n'a plus le
droit d'aller chercher les lettres de
son mari alors non d'ailleurs je te
ferai remarquer que je ne l'est pas est
pas ouverte à tous et qui dit toujours
que je te filme si je te file est bon
tu ne les lis pas quoi tes lettres
pourquoi tu as le temps ça veut dire
qu'il ya quelque chose que tu ne veux
pas me montrer qu'il fallait que je sois
parti pour que tu lises vous crois que
tu vaux nuit mondiaux coutume non mais
la voilà elle vient de me demandez pas
d'où tiens là voilà ben tiens bon tiens
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il y ait dans
ces lettres lille est dit les vois pas
pourquoi je te les cacheraient ils sont
sans importance et que l'éclat étudiants
mon cher collègue je n'ai pas oublié les
30 louis que je vous dois
et si je vous écris ses côtés tient à
m'acquitter est bien là tu vois c'est un
collègue qui me rend 30 louis tauran
témoin dont 20 louis cela fera une somme
ronde que je vous rendrai au premier
jour à bientôt
par exemple je te félicite de la façon
dont tu comprends les placements et
celle là d'une écriture plus fine avec
cette devise quelque peu arrogante qui
me prends mes fidèles
je me prends mes futurs achats direz
vous que ça n'est pas une femme vous
comprends pas monsieur en vain le joli
la femme monsieur dans le succès obtenu
par notre nouvelle invention la
mignonnette nous nous faisons un devoir
de vous recommander ce gracieux
appareils hydrauliques
c'est à juste titre qu'il a pu adopter
comme devise qui me prends mes fidèles
bien la voilà ta femme non non non mais
c'est agaçant à la fin car tout ce que
je peux à tout va sans se cacher que je
puisse même plus dire à la cuisinière
voudrait bien manger du veau ce soir
sans qu'on ne s'imagine que ça signifie
que je vais passer la nuit avec elle eh
bien je te déclare qu avec ce système là
tu finiras pas me faire quitter la
maison si tu veux le savoir
tu quitterait la maison parfaitement
gétaz famille en province vachement
dirais je retournerais chez ma mère
l'aide motion rim ferait passagers
j'aime ce tournoi
là encore j'ai eu tort oui oui ça
j'aurais dû réfléchir attendre avant de
ta qc ça tu apprends rien
oui non mais qu'est ce que tu veux c'est
ce qui me rend méfiante et toutes ces
histoires de robinho côté de l'ars ont
les yeux et comprendre ma chère amie que
tu fais absolument fausse route avec ton
carnet posthume
mais en admettant même que j'ai l'idée
de tromper mais quoi tu que j'irai
recourir à ces vieilles cuisse elle
annonça au moins quand demain que sera
original je suis pas vaudevilliste moi
j'ai pas besoin des idées des autres
pour faire des pièces nouvelles
alors écoutez écoutez moi ne fait pas de
pièces du tout
les ingénieurs et bien ne fait pas comme
monsieur ingres n'essaie pas de jouer du
violon oui et bien toi alors même père
soit pas tout le temps que j'en joue non
mais c'est vrai tu finiras comme donner
le goût de la musique écoutée elle tout
ça c'est beaucoup de ta faute tu sais si
je sentais que tu m'aimais bien je
n'aurais peut-être pas ses idées je ne
t'aime pas moi au bout pas comme mon
premier temps si tu crois qu'une femme
s'y trompe il ya des soirs où tu ne me
dit même pas bonjour oui aux foires
autrefois tu me le disait plutôt deux
fois qu'une
oh non non battus même plus otan-russie
messi mais six seulement ces discussions
continuelles qu'est ce que tu veux ça
fatigue la tendresse que c'est logique
quoi toute expansion de quelque ordre
qu'elle soit exige une dépense nerveuse
et bien étant donné que nous n'avons
qu'à certaines capitales quotidien si
nous dépensons d'un côté nous ne
dépensons pas de l'autre dû me fait une
scène mon budget y passe je me repose
il faut croire que je suis plus riche
que toi mais c'est possible mais moi je
suis comme un homme qui n'aurait que 20
francs à dépenser par jour s'il s'achète
dans sa journée pour 20 francs de poil à
gratter
il aura pour faire une rapide sous quand
il veut raspail à deviner il pourra
aller dîner en ville oui eh bien je ne
veux pas moi que tu as à dyneon vie mais
non c'est parce que je voulais dire non
non je veux que tu me dis qu'avec moi
les wii la wii
seulement arrange toi qu'on ne peut pas
m'enlever l'appétit c'est entendu il
alors je t'embrasse tu m'embrasses les
droits comment sont plus on avec ça je
te le promets et vous croyez que ça va
la corriger nommé pour l'instant à sofia
rien monsieur avant c'est bien là qu'est
ce que vous voulez que ça c'est une
dépêche pour l'issue à donner la
et bien senti qu est-ce que c'est ça
c'est une dépêche pour monsieur x
égyptien en baisse marquée est bien j'ai
eu avec sa mademoiselle
comment se fait-il que vous remettiez à
madame les dépêches qui me sont adressés
que monsieur je ne suis pas quoi dire à
monsieur mais j'ai promis à madame irma
la mort donnée j'ai bien imparfaite
elle vous a peut être su donner de
l'argent pour ça monsieur bah quoi c'est
vrai on me sens là monsieur et combien
mal à vous at elle donné vaf au départ
on d'agir de la sorte ça dans quelle
maison avez vous une domestique reçoit
de l'argent pour monsieur on te donner
dela 30 fois vous rendrez à madame ses
20 francs et à l'avenir vous remettrez
tout à ma belle et autant que possible
quand madame ne sera pas allé comme ça
très vite monsieur s'est entendu
monsieur si même monsieur voulait aller
jusqu'à 40 franc je lui remettrai les
lettres de madame et vous l'avez vous
on sonne à les ouvrir c'est pour moi
vous prierais d'attendre vous dirais que
j'ai une dépêche à écrire les encore
heureux que j'ai surpris le complot à
temps il aurait pu tomber tel ou tel est
en tournée man ma femme on le sait bien
de dieu quelle émotion
c'est véritablement quand on est éloigné
des gens qu'on s'aperçoit de leur
absence à les prévenir votre maîtresse
et qui annoncerait jama d'aristide homme
heureux ou plutôt non non non non a
lancé un ami retour de bata bien ça doit
être long a fait de l'autre côté de
l'eau qui a livré la nouvelle cabine
jusqu'à moi mal dont us il m'est plus
pauvres robineau monsieur robinet on et
voilà deux 2 ans et l'on dit que le
temps efface le chagrin pauvre chat g 2
et je le pleure encore mais vous ne
savez peut être pas depuis longtemps de
plus un quart d'heure aux descendants du
chemin de fer j'ai couru à l'ancienne
demeure des robin ou là on m'a appris la
perte de mon ami un ami que jamais comme
un frère j'ai demandé l'adresse de sa
veuve et et me voilà au hausse avec la
rude coup pour moi
voyez ici alors ici on habitue d'hab on
est habitués ou bien on était haut le
voilà ce cher amis tels que je les ai
connus
c'est bien embellie eh bien je vais
prévenir madame ce soit légal
mon pauvre ami
je vais donc pouvoir épouser ta femme
maintenant c'est de pouvoir prendre
votre place en te faire une salle déjà
aurait pu occuper de ton vivant
peut-être mais j'ai préféré une
expatriée plutôt que de m'exposer à la
tentation de tromper un ami que jamais
comme un frère
car je t'aime mais de toute la force de
mon affection tu m'avais rendu un de ses
services qui vous attaches pour la vie
j'allais me marier une femme charmante
qui m'avait offert sa main d'elles-mêmes
jallet convoler tu es venu à moi et m'a
dit tu ne les pousse pas je flair que tu
le regretterai je ne l'est pas épouser
et trois mois après elle était mère oui
ce n'était pas par amour qu'elle m'avait
offert sam
tu me suis toujours gré du service que
tu m'avais rendu et dès ce jour
je fus chez moi chez toi tout ce qui est
à moi ma tu dis tout est à toi tout
excepté ma femme pourquoi juste excepté
sa femme ça ne devait pas manquer je
veux bien te l'avouer maintenant gens de
20 follement amoureux brusquement sans
savoir pourquoi
par une journée de rage il faisait chaud
elle avait une chenille qui grimpaient
sur le col elle me dit oh
enlevez moi ça moi je m'approchais
poliment sans penser mais son coût était
là avec des cheveux mon cou qui faisait
pas piloter mes yeux un coût qui me
paraissait l'onduleuse yeux dans le
vague
alors un baiser m'a échappé il paraît
parce que je ne m'en suis pas rendu
compte
j'entendis la voix de notre angèle dans
un rêve
oh c'est bien man ce que nous faisons là
ça m'a fait peur je me suis tombé comme
un fou mon coeur battait j'ai pris un
cachet d'antibes il est tout de suite
courant
non et le lendemain j'ai accepté un
poste des conciles à batavia voilà voilà
robineau ce que c'était pour toi je suis
parti jusqu'à batavia sans regarder en
arrière parce que j'étais un vrai ami
pour toi je me disais tu n'as pas le
droit de songer à sa femme tant qu'il
est là mais ne désespère pas robineau
fait une hausse carabine et il laissera
sa peau alors tu pourras reparaître et
posé sa femme sans remords
ce n'est plus le bien d'un ami que tu
dérobera non c'est sa succession que tu
recueillir et ça ça se fait dans les
familles les plus unis j'ai attendu
tu n'es plus et me voilà quelle joie de
vous revoir les exilés parce que je vous
aime et que je n'avais pas le droit de
vous le dire angèle angèle comme c'est
peu de chose la vie oui pourquoi ne
dites-vous si parquet l'épreuve il faut
passer au le voilà ce cher ami pauvre
femme avec quels cultes vous garder son
image qui robineau à parlons sa jolie
peau qu un
on va vous avez vu comme moi que c'était
un tarif il est l'un des poumons
c'est bien il m'a trompée tromper tout
ça bizarre je vous conseille de le plein
ce que vous me dites là me fait de la
peine ne remplissent voix parce que
sinon l'état si je puis dire que je
n'aurais pas eu à souffrir de son
souvenir parce que si jamais vous faites
une comparaison elle ne pourrait être
qu'à mon avantage comment un tel point
qu'elle propose ce propos qu'il n'y a
plus d'obstacles entre nous que je vous
aime et que je viens vous dire épouse en
nous
vous épousez voulu maintenant il y as a
qu'un tout petit obstacle
mon mari oui je suis remarié mon ami
alors on attend d'en cesser ses tubes
c'est une épreuve n'est ce pas vous
l'auriez pas fait ça je n'en crois pas
un mot
tenez vous allez me demander à mon mari
lui même le voici donc quelques salons
et mathieu automne bretois à paris série
b tu es bien qu'est-ce que tu vas ça va
bien et une autre fois comment l'autre
fois il appelle salle reçoit ya trois
ans je ne les ai pas vus non non non
trois ans tu sais que je suis marié
voici de ma femme laisse moi te
présenter bonjour madame nouvelle susan
après celle ci dit monsieur timbre n'est
pas un inconnu pour moi nous avions
quelques fois l'occasion de le voir sous
le premier régime
oui autant de ce pauvre robineau au le
voilà sous thérapie qui l'eût cru tout
de même un si bon vivant homeaway lui si
plein de santé 1 quand on pense que j'ai
pas dans la note alors que voilà
définitivement à paris tu ne retourne
plus à batavia si demain comment si on
voit la nuit des coups quand on arrive à
une telle déception que ce que j'ai
mieux à faire c'est de m'en aller à
londres des déceptions en voilà des
raisons d'un calque histoires de femmes
une infidèle qui te rahouli mais n'a
jamais rien n'était pour moi et ben
alors y'a rien de perdu eh bien c'est ce
que je te dis attends ton tour viendra
achever le promets
mais mais ça ne dépend pas de toit assez
dommage se serait fait ça serait fait au
brave ami va les maris en quelques fois
la profonde malheureux en attendant nous
ne gardons ici où sont tes bagages les
bagages mais à l'hôtel de france et des
bains s'est passé mais je vais les
envoyer prendre et nous allons installer
chez nous et j'ai tout un petit pavillon
à ta disposition dangeard d'alors mais
je ne souffrirai pas non meuleuse dont
le ton non mais ça n'est pas possible
mon ami ben non il n'est pas sa vie nous
mêmes mais pour lui ça n'a pas
d'importance
voilà ce qu'il y avait il est plein de
cancrelats où c'est ce qui m'empêche de
le louer pas parce que des étrangers
mais pour un ami c'est tout ce qu'il
faut c'était bien légal n'est ce pas
c'est pas des pauvres cancrelats
parisiens qui font reculer à un homme
qui vient de batam olalalala mais
abattent un bien qu'on nous avions des
cancrelats c'est lé score puisque les
champions mais bis qui avait même 30 cm
de long s'ils voient ils font chambre
commune avec des scorpions 30 centimères
imagine tudella en bouche de ceux
promouvant la chambre c'est dire qu'il
va se croire en tout les bêtes à bon
dieu dans ce pavillon que cette assure
satis radio mais du tout du tout je ne
peux pas le nous et tant qu'il sera dans
cet état aussi cette volée mais je
t'assure où j'ai donné des ordres pour
compléter ce pavillon mais j'étais
assommé c'est ici je n'ose vraiment pas
accepter l'offre de bâton c'est à la
maison et je vous demande de ne pas
l'accepter pourquoi parce qu'après tout
ce que vous m'aviez fait dit tout à
l'heure après vous avez à mots couverts
n'a devant mon mari après ce qui s'est
passé entre nous ces jeunes ne vient pas
c'est pas juste pas d'en face il s'était
passé quelque chose
ce qui est fait est fait et il n'y aura
plus qu'à laisser courir mais depuis ce
qu'il n'ya rien puisque nous avons pu
l'un et l'autre sortir intact d'un
moment de défaillance je fais allusion
jour daurade vous vous souvenez ces
jours là
la femme est plein de contradictions
j'aimais pourtant robineau mai
mais la folie l'affolement l'art
heureusement heureusement vous êtes
parti à avoir le moment précis talent
mais j'aimais robinho comme un frère
c'est votre timidité qui m'a sauvé en
plus d'heureux
non non si maintenant il est vraiment
tout à fait inutile que nous continuons
à vivre l'un près de l'autre de se
contacter de chaque jour ne pourrait
n'être qu'une une contrainte pour moi et
dès qu'une inspiration de ressentiment
pour vous ainsi parce que vous avez
épousé ribadier au lieu de matin vous
saviez que je vous ai veille il faut que
je m'éloigne que je m'exile non
seulement la femme ne peut être à moi
mais il m'est même interdit de l'avoir
c'est pour votre bien mettez de côté
pour le bien de ribadier alors le voilà
l'homme à qui je suis obligé de me
sacrifier à sa vous l'aimiez donc vous
l'avait épousée
pas tant que ça pourquoi alors je ne
pouvais pas rester en position fausse
ribadier me paraissait pas mort
ajoutez à cela son nom ribadier si c'est
pour s'appeler ribadier ah ah ça y est
pour beaucoup
ribadier robineau méme initial pas
besoin de faire des marques et molène
niveau argent
c'est ça le mariage d'économie je
connaissais le mariage d'amour le
mariage de raison mais ce mariage la non
non non cool épouser l'homme parce qu'il
a tout dit moustache
s'il porte de la toile ça je le
comprends mais ton les blues pour le pas
des marques et on lave annonçait un
pognon ça me dépasse
mais j'aurais payé le démarquage moi je
l'aurais payer que je laime à présent
puisque je le voulais mais c'est à moi
de le dire elle n'est pas satisfaite de
la blessure dont lé cause il faut encore
qu'elle ils refont saison vous voyez
bien qu'il faut que vous partiez vous
avez raison j'arrive aujourd'hui de
batavia bien j'y retournerai de marc
atteindre dans le voyage pour venir
passer une soirée à paris
naturellement vous allez bien trouver un
prétexte pour expliquer votre départ
précipité auprès de mon mari
et bien maintenant adieu mon avis à dieu
pour tous mais bon j'ai longé fonctionne
- premier témoin une chose personnelle
et éternel ici-bas ribadier comme moi
pouvons disparaître d'un jour à l'autre
si jamais ce malheur nous arriver à l'un
ou à l'autre rom était moins que vous
m'écrivez immédiatement à donner je suis
libre l'été c'est pourquoi il vient pas
par nettoyer l'huile de vidange et enfin
j'y compte n'est ce pas au la raison la
raison il vaut mieux que je regagne
batavia au plus vite que te retourne les
scorpions
je n'ai rien à espérer ici elle aime son
mari et elle lui sera fidèle fabula ça y
est j'ai dit qu'on arrange le pavillon
non non c'est inutile vois tu je préfère
m'en aller le commandant je croyais
cette déconvenue
tu n'as pas le désespoir guérétois un an
que tu n'aurais vers 2h on nous allons
nous nous changer deux des gays rien n'a
pu me payer
mais à paris peu du lyra rim devient
odieux mais voyons ne suis-je pas joyeux
compagne racines en fait ma femme
n'est-elle pas charmant n'y a rien à
faire
qu'est ce que tu dis
rien à faire pour moi à paris et de se
parler au mari je te dis que je m'en
allais te retourner à batave du taureau
et puis rhodia le tube est tu restera la
même trame et sapristi on n'est pas
stupides comme ça pour une femme
si tu crois c'est un moyen d'arriver à
tf1 mais au lieu de désespérer attaques
dont marche
non merci mais c'est comme je te le dis
mais elle ne viendra pas me chercher du
tout me vois hulot ne connaît rien à
l'amour tu as loupé tiens veux tu me
donnes état procuration non mais rien
pour te montrer tu verras comment je
mène une campagne
et bien voilà je fais connaissance avec
une dame je les suis dit je l'atteins
non non non ne me dis pas que la tatra
jeu la tâte je tâte le terrain qu'est ce
que tu vas comprendre
je trouve le défaut de la cuirasse et je
t'enlève salat robot battant nantes et
toi tu es toi tais toi tu m'as folle
suis à bout et rouge
je vois bien que tu te méfies toi tu as
peur que je te souffle sa dulcinée moi
toi mais je t'assure que ce n'est pas la
coutume chez moi il y a 6 ans étant
entendu que je t'ai supplanter auprès de
mimi marvejols a même eu marjolin ne
porte une farceuse tu m'as supplanter
toi comment tu ne le savais pas il me
l'avait jamais dit ah je croyais 10 dont
10 dont je la trouve mauvaise mais
qu'est ce que ça te fait puisque tu n'es
plus avec elle bassam est désagréable
qu'est ce que tu dirais si après avoir
bu un bon verre de quelque chose dont tu
devais te dire je veux bien vous
l'avouer maintenant le domestique avait
craché dans on a beau avoir l'idée de
voir c'est dégoûtant adventure mais si
ta comparaison non c'est pour dire c'est
pour dire tu marchais dans mes plats
devant toi bats mon vieux si je peux un
jour tu marques
alors c'est convenu tu me donnes ta
procuration food apporte une mariée
quand on est mardi on s'occupe de son
ménage pas d'autre chose
mais napoléon d'ictère deux secrétaires
à la fois mais tu n'es pas napoléon face
à madame ribadier n'est pas jaloux donc
pas jalouse l eau au dieu ça vous
l'entendez pas jalouse mais alors
inventé la jalousie dont elle est bien
gentil mais il ya des moments où elle me
rend la vie devient insupportable
mais alors tu n'es pas heureux mais ne
soit pas tous deux roues il n'est pas
heureux c'est vrai que le malheur des
uns fait parfois le bonheur
et dire qu autrefois elle était si
confiant titre et d'une longue et plus
que tu allais chez autrefois robin
waddle devant dieu sait pourtant qu'il
n'y en a fait voir de toutes les
couleurs et quand je dis lui en a fait
voir il y en a fait et il ne les lui a
pas fait voir et bien il a fallu que
c'est imbécile de robin ne dit pas
imbécile je l'aimais comme un frère eh
bien je dirais pas rêver si je dirais
ton france et ça et bien il a fallu que
ton frère
robineau et bien les sa dont ses papiers
un inventaire de tous les trucs
l'employé pour tromper sa femme alors
c'est pas ouvert les yeux danger sur le
compte de robinho et tous les mariés en
général est ce qu'il ya de terrible
c'est que si jamais je crois mais
quelque chose mais je la connais une
femme indicative et ne devrait pas mais
sera capable de ma fille j'ai la peine
du talion il me dit oh oui oui oui tu ne
peux pas la tromper mais je dirais pas
jusqu'à dire ça mais ceux qui ne foutent
précaution me tiens justement en ce
moment vient dire au monde
la fameuse d'un négociant en vin une
brune charmant vie mais comment trompes
tu la surveillance de ta femme
puisqu'elle est initié à tous les trucs
je ne la trompe pas sa surveillance le
jeu long de sa surveillance
non mais encore j'ai mon système à moi
puis 2 ressemble en rien aux trucs et
vont hanter dro 2011 il avait des moyens
d'amateurs bon moyen à moi relève de la
science ne comprend pas la prochaine
expérience je te convoque avec plaisir
et pour ça il faut que tu restes à paris
que tu n'auras tour de pas tout de suite
à batavia attend mieux au oui je reste
je crois bien que je reste
et bien c'est prévu si tu veux boire des
appartements volante il en profitera
pour me verser un peu d'eau sur les mâts
prévient sophie vallet une dépêche qui
est arrivé au cercle pour monsieur n'est
qu'un chasseur vient d'apporter merci
j'ai fait remarquer à monsieur que je la
remets à lui même je m'en serais pas
douter si vous ne l'aviez pas tout de
suite
d'épaisses voyance thérèse s'affinaient
seidel
dire que cette dépêche aurait pu tomber
entre lehmann ma femme non on côtoie
tout le temps des précipices dans la vie
bbbb c'est moi bv mon mari a été appelée
brusquement bourgogne pour acheter une
récolte sur pied ma soirée est libre
j'ai donné campo domestique je t'attends
à 9 heures je veux mes chats freestyle
8h30 j'ai par rapport à mai tombe bien
je n'ai coltan impliqué le grand moyens
tous les partis et oui il a regagné le
pavillon je ne regarde pas il m'en
fallait donc toujours neutre alors
regardez moi dans les yeux dans les
mains dans les mains
est ce que j'ai l'air d'un mari
quitteront est ce que je te regarderai
comme ça oui je te trompes tu me vois
donc pas rare que je t'ai
mais ça y est le système ribadier
pendant ce temps recueil ça un beau lieu
à marseille ce serait très bien là et
bien là tant mieux et bien je sors tu
descends avec moi mais je gèle enfin de
madame ta femme lui fait pas attention
regarde donc est-ce qu'il ya ça m a
poussé le système ribadier elle va
dormir comme ça pendant mon absence et
quand je reviendrai je souffle dessus
elle s'éveille et diminue connu le cul
mais que fais tu là je ferme à cause des
domestiques et je baisse la lampe pour
ne pas attirer l'attention du dehors
mais tu vas fermer ici aussi bien oui
voilà voilà
là où vas tu peux prendre on va quand
même que tu as des as les bienvenus oui
oui voilà voilà voilà
après tout lui n'est qu'un ami je ne
l'aiment pas comme un frère
[Applaudissements]
sophie n'a pas oublié elle a laissé la
fenêtre entrouverte
d'ailleurs pour une question d'amour une
femme n'oublie jamais bon il s'agit
d'enjamber maintenant allez je me suis
accroché il ya quelque chose qui a
craqué bah si c'est une déchirure avec
une bonne reprise recife noir tient
pourtant la lampre pas complètement
éteint au fait que ça moi j'ai touché
quelque chose de chaud à mon dieu c'est
peut-être la chienne qui s'est glissée
dans le salon
c'est encore heureux qu'elle n'a pas
mordu à pour m'apprendre à lui diraient
les voiles la fenêtre est grande ouverte
je l'avais pourtant qu'entre bayer il
aura eu un coup de vent que ce soit
devant ou pas le vent l'heure est
propice et les instants son cours
allô allô je voudrais dire que mon coeur
ne va pas je mentirais il me semble que
j'ai un mouvement de pendule dans la
poitrine 9 heures c'est l'heure du crime
à batavia allons allons allons chaud
trop chaud pas très baisse je joue les
roméo mois j'escalade les fenêtres
c'est à dire je les escalades quand
elles ne dépassent pas le rez de
chaussée parce que dame au dessus avec
sac romeo se serait amusé si juliette a
vécu son balcon au cinquième au dessus
de l'entresol cyril batié me voyais ça
m'embêterait s'il me voyais pas ce qu'il
n'ya pas à dire mon bonhomme s'annonce
ce que je fais là ça s'appelle une grâce
quand un ami vous donnent l'hospitalité
c'est mal vu de lui prendre sa femme
c'est mal vu je le sais mais ça se fait
beaucoup
la seule chose que j'ai à dire c'est que
je lève et qu'elle est belle regardez là
n'est elle pas je lis ainsi un frère
humain ce pardon billet je résisterai
dans l'eau non il n'ya pas d'amis qui tu
y arrives à te venir je lui dirai le
m'accable parents de m'entendre 1
seulement m'excuseras j'avais envie de
ta femme prochaine oui oui c'est moi
c'est moi ne me repousse et pas je suis
un grand coupable est elle demande à
angèle nouvelle
angèle sa piste est dure comme un sapeur
pourtant pas lui faire mal de crâne pas
déclarations fin d'après- venir
on gèle on n'y a pas à m'en être tiré
des coups de revolver et encore ça ne
l'a révèlerai pas ça amènerait la maison
en endommageant le plafond mais que
faire si nos déchets le maintien mais
ribadier me l'a donné le moyen pour sa
tour il va dire oui je souffle dessus
elle se réveille et ni vu ni connu
le voilà le moyen souffler je vais faire
comme il m'a dit je vais lui souffler sa
femme
vous suivez
[Musique]
au moins je me suis encore endormis oui
si oui c'est pas chez moi je suis un
grand copain ne me poussez pas nous
retient de lui préjuger de la société en
challenge et je vous aime les pc de fou
que faites vous où est mon mari vous
inquiétez pas votre mari est loin le
ciel nous protège et louer ces marchands
de tabac il n'avait plus de cigares mais
mais mais allez-vous chat en voyant le
marchand de tabac est à côté pour
l'amour du ciel redire non non non non
il est à l'énergie à côté décideurs ne
sont pas frais en challenge je vous en
supplie écoutez moi si c'est moi laissez
vous aller au sentiment que vous dicte
votre hackers n'écoutez pas les
raisonnements sur un nez de votre
conscience je vous aime vous m'aimez
vous aime pas si vous m'aimez si vous
m'aimez songé contre x 100 ma timidité
vous l'avez mais non mon coeur n'y était
pour rien je ne vous ai même pas c'était
la chèvre seulement donc moins davantage
mois la polygamie lente de mon mari
c'est ignoble
vous faites alors oui c'est ignoble
c'est ignoble mais c'est humain non je
ne mangeais yodelice et moi vous ne vous
êtes pas dit que vous commettiez une
horrible telonis ici si je me suis dit
dix fois vingt fois revient à la 20e
enfin vous qui m'avez donné votre parole
qui va bien promis de retourner à bata à
retourner à gattaca
elle me demande de retourner à batavia
congé de l'amour là le coeur quand je
déborde à vous l'espérez pas bien non
non je n'y retournerai pas à batavia
olala avez vous dû me tenir un assez
piètre estime quand j'y suis allé à
batavia en pas du tout au contraire j'ai
dit voilà oui c'est ce que je dis un bon
appel s'il bouge c'est ce que parler
veut dire mais du mois cette fois ci
j'avais su l'excusera opinion que jamais
comme un frère
c'est pour lui que je suis parti c'était
pas une raison madame pour que je le
fasse pour tous ses successeurs aux
matières ici d'aller là bas ça a permis
au malin de profiter de mon absence pour
s'emparer de la place et quand je suis
revenu à la déprise la place vous vous
étiez remarier pour ne pas démarrer
votre linge
aux pieds vous saviez que je voulais
être à moi c'est mon bien qu'il m'a pris
à vaureilles page 9 heures maison
bientôt leur cela c'est le droit et pour
moi je m'en fiche la loi comme pour
donner mais je ne sais qu'une chose
c'est ton mal aisé que je suis spoliés
que je vais reprendre ce qui m'a marqué
entendez vous je vous dis que je vous ai
mon coeur déborde et des flots de poésie
monte au cerveau je me sens doit être
vous dit prête si je voulais disait
pourtant que je vous aime
qui sait brune aux yeux bleus ce que
vous en tiriez l'amour vous le savez
cause une peine extrait c'est de musset
vous croyez c'est possible j'ai pas dis
que c'est une loi seule miss elle a
écrit moi je n'ai pensé
angèle angèle dites moi que vous m'aimez
bien oui mais à une condition
vous voulez mon la wii est bien à vous
de le gagner
et quoi je puisse espérer au ma vie s'il
le faut demandez moi de me tuer devant
vous si vous devez m'appartenir
je ne vous en demande pas tant
retournez à batavia voilà tout elle
appelle son avocate des continents des
mères tout cet espace entre nous mais ça
me donnera là la mesure de votre jeune
mais furent pas mon amour au kilomètre
attendre et vous ne m'aimez pas si je
vous aime si je t'aime c'est bien pour
ça que je ne veux pas avant d'aller me
rendais pas compte de ce que vous me
demandez la mecs il est là bas me forcer
à aller me ronger aux 100000 diable en
l'accordant quoi que mon tour arrive en
être réduit à souhaiter la disparition
d'un homme d'un honnête homme d'un homme
qui vous avez vous dirait mon prochain
après tout bien non non ma conscience se
révoltent à une pareille idée est plutôt
que d'attendre qu'il ne soit plus pour
odieux j'aime autant lui prendre sa
femme tout de suite et qu'ils devaient
tendre
sans compter qu'on ne sait jamais ce que
ça dure a mal aux pauvres lipatti là
vous voyez bien que vous êtes ému mais
ce que je n'ai pas raison voyons est ce
que ça ne sera pas bien plus charmant
ainsi nous organiserons une bonne petite
existence à nous trois
la vie calme de ménage tout ça bien là
sa commodité bien entendu parce que il
ne faudrait pas qu'ils en souffrit le
pauvre garçon et nous le dorlote ronde
le cajole rend ce sera le plus heureux
des hommes
nous le tromperont tous les deux et nous
nous aimerons tous les trois noms france
pas le paradis gens non vous êtes fou et
je ne comprends pas vos scrupules mais
les fans l'épisode y est on fait ça en
fait non seulement ça ne s'est pas
suivre la toux mais il phare fourmis de
ses héroïnes qui avait su concilier
leurs devoirs avec leur pension
mais l'histoire sans être même
l'histoire sainte vous savez les
principes religieux vous et bien
l'histoire sainte est pleine de ces
exemples soir c'est non un exode des mre
mars et vénus tonus le nez de vulcain
l'apesa 10 mars inquiète
nous perdons un temps précieux vous vous
montrerez parole pour gagner du temps
je vous mets mon épingle et qu'est ce
que ça signifie
c'est une infamie d'amoureuse vous
horton d'ouvriers non c'est trop fort
thomas ouvrait ses portes aux sétois la
clé quoi c'est votre mari c'est votre
mari que vous enfermez mon mari pourquoi
ressasser les secrets d'un bon alors il
me reste la france
c'est c'est la sonnerie de la porte
cochère deux coups c'est mon ami si son
mari de coûts c'est son mari qui revient
comme il a été vite mais qu'est ce qui
vous prend au mont dieu mon dieu en
gironde
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait il le contre
la porte comme s'ils voulaient empêcher
quelqu'un d'entre elles sont bien nous
sommes déjà nous voilà violent mais
qu'est ce que vous avez à courir comme
ça je ne cours pas pour page envisage
une situation
il ya vous avez une droite de façon
d'envisager qu'il avait si bien endormi
quand il la trouvera débile pour prendre
à tout entier qualité tu l'endormir à
mon tour j'ai pensé dont je venais ici
on peut les citer ceux qui ce qui avait
donné regardez moi bien dans les yeux là
lorsque vous êtes drôle mais non mais
non non je ne suis pas drôle ne riez pas
regarder droit à des vidéos regardées
vous vous ne sentez rien votre santé
rien ici sigean sahel sont restaurés
font ils ont des réponses meti une odeur
de café d'en face ont des cheveux je
parle intérieurement mais qu'elle soit
venue plus tard essayé essayé mais le
seuil est quoi arrêt de sentir
je ne pensais pas le fluide de feu qui
couvre les voix off dit il
essayez vous l'avez fait semblant de
dormir et me bouger de votre marie le
guen lui même vous réveiller mais qu'est
ce que ça signifie vous dirai plus tard
mais quoi que vous entendiez pas un cri
pas un geste rien je vous en supplie il
y va des conséquences les plus graves
mais qu'est ce que vous faites je
rétablis la mise en scène est maintenant
je me sauve pas un mot vous entendez pas
ce monde en supplie
dormez je le veux dormez dormez en fait
défaut qu'est-ce qu'il a aux îles se
passe ici quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est mon mari il n'est pas celle aux
marckois senti d'orvault j'aurais
peut-être comme ça la clé de l'énigme
enfin ça veut dire j'adore toujours je
suis tranquille mais enfin monsieur me
dire ou ce que vous voulez je ne vous
connais pas c'est bien le seul et ne
criez pas je dois vous dire ce qu'il en
est mais avant fait sortir malgré votre
fille ma fille ça ma fille là c'est ma
femme alors fait sentir votre femme ce
que j'ai à vous dire ne doit être
entendue que de nous vous pouvez parler
sans crainte monsieur ma femme dort et
quand elle est dans cet état on pourrait
tirer le canot à côté qu'elle ne
l'entendrait pas n'ayant pas de canons
sur moi monsieur je ne puis en faire
l'expérience
mais du moment que vous me l'assuré je
n'irai pas par quatre chemins
un mot vous dira tout je suis monsieur
savinet satiné mais monsieur sans me
dire y'a du tout à ça ne vous dit rien
je vais être plus explicite mais chez
vous êtes l'avant de ma femme
moi oui vous lu misérables c'est tout à
leur métier chez madame sabine est quand
je suis rentré inopinément vous qui en
m'entendant vous être vécue est lente et
vous êtes sans fil par le salon alors
que je n'entrais pas le couloir mais pas
assez vite pour que je me mets lance sur
votre jeu je ne sais ce que vous voulez
dire si madame votre femme a un amant ce
n'est pas moi vous vous serez tromper de
piste dans la rue bobbitt alors monsieur
voulez-vous me dire pourquoi vous avez
mon chapeau et pourquoi j'ai le ventre
vous vous êtes trompé de chapeau dans
l'autisme et bien oui là mais c'est rêve
de mensonges c'est moi qui étais chez
madame se vit à londres
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire qu'il
m alors si vous voulez moi venir où je
veux en venir
il me demande où je veux en venir mais
monsieur vous m'avez couvert de ridicule
non me permettre monsieur je sais ce que
je dis à mari trompé est toujours
ridicule
je ne sais si madame votre femme vous
amis à l'école la pression ab pardon
monsieur n'en savais rien et ne vous a
guère monsieur je ne suis pas un homme
dp je suis un marchand de vin mais
retenez bien ceci si vous dites à guide
ce soit que vous êtes l'amant de la
femme
je vous tuerai 1 1 je ne tiens pas à me
battre moi d'ailleurs pour qu'ils se
battent pour la société aussi la société
dépend au courant un sas entasser les us
alors tout ce que je vais vous demander
c'est qu'on ne sachant rien dans
quelques temps ge divorceraient d'avec
ma femme et personne jamais ne se serait
douté de la vérité je vous le répète je
suis mme ashton balle et je ne veux pas
d'un scandale qui causerait le plus
grand préjudice amène à faire et qui me
des considérerait à verser entraînement
la loge et connaissez pas mais un
marchand de vin qui seraient soupçonnés
d'être il tiendrait pas michaud a pas
assez comme je vous le dis donc
j'exige votre silence schéma galanterie
vous en répondre d'ailleurs c'est bien
simple un seul mot et je vous dirai
d'accord monsieur mais enfin me dis
toujours je vous tuerai pourquoi de
supposées vous pas l'hypothèse contrat
non monsieur vous n'en avez pas le droit
non vous ne rêvez pas droit ce sont de
nos prérogatives à nous autres mario
france et il faut bien que nous en ayons
quelques-unes
l'amour doit se laisser tuer s'il s'est
montré qu'il s'est dit
d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi je vous dis
que sans être fort aux armes
je vous tuerai non mais permettez non
s'il y avait un homme qui ait le droit
de piquer des sports ce n'est plus un
rituel
c'est une opération chirurgicale je le
regrette c'est la règle merci
mais bon votre cognac va retrouver harry
très bon n'est pas tout purin ya des
armagnacs aller qu'est ce que vous payez
sa 8 francs 8 francs en caisse qui
doivent gag
elle dort toujours eh bien monsieur mois
pour 6 francs je me fais fort de vous
avoir une fine champagne aussi bonne que
ça en réalité
aie aie aie et si elle ne vous plaît pas
je vous l'apprends j'en ai quelques
pièces mais dépêchez vous eh bien
monsieur je ne dis pas à nantes je lui
dois bien ça du cognac maintenant faite
le c'est bien ça vous après vous m'en
direz des nous nous disons un monsieur
je me battrai pas dit oui au reste ma
femme doit connaître votre nom en fin du
mois je le suppose donc une pièce une
champagne 65 ribadier ce sera payable à
votre choix
content avec 5% des secondes à 90 jours
sans et ce commentaire je dois bien
d'autres commodités
on n'est pas plus aimable alors voilà
qui est fait alors c'est bien contenu
par faites pas si vous dites un
montjavoult 2-1 non pardon mais je n'y
pensais plus oui c'est convenu toujours
à vos ordres mais monsieur je vous
reconduis tropez nabeul c'est une femme
du musée grévin cette femme là
un joli portrait un grand grand homme
c'est un diamant non ça c'est le mari de
ma femme à 7,2 mais comment mieux
maintenant c'est le premier set
j'aimerais pas savoir pourquoi sarah non
parce que deux chevaux c'est un peu
comme le dit d'aidé domestique
ça a déjà passé à la table des maîtres
m'ont dit monsieur chacun dean comme il
peut en tout cas j'aime encore mieux
être à ma place qu'à la sienne des goûts
et des couleurs m'envole un malotru elle
est vrai que je vous en prie monsieur
par ici sabeg heureusement dur et puis
vous savez si vous avez besoin d'un bon
pontet canet je vous aurai une
excellente occasion carla et la canaille
la canaille demande encore comment j'ai
fait pendant pour me contenir pendant
tout ce temps là comment je ne vais pas
étrangler dix fois ça me fait du bien de
les boucher à bord alors le voilà dos
aux marchands de tabac c'était la femme
de cet imbécile qui vivent du cognac
il sera exécrable sont cogné a
naturellement une fois fêtera de la
circonstance pour lui écoulé tous ces
vieux stocks abandonnés au mais ce sera
bien fait pour lui et je le forcerait à
le boire jusqu'à la dernière goutte son
cognac à mon bonhomme vous allez voir de
quel bois je me chauffe
robotics immunitaire mots je vous tuerai
et je vais la réveiller je t'en donnerai
mois d'états arabes oublier qu'on est
capable femme réveillée elle était venue
vous attendez pas à le trouver à ce
qu'il paraît non si l'on tombé ça comme
un combat des plus éveillés à la perfide
d'où viens tu es aux dons le dire d'où
tu viens d'où je viens tu veux savoir
d'où je viens et bien tu mens j'ai
encore rien dit eh bien je vais te le
dire ouais tu viens tu viens de 7 à
maîtresse madame sabine est sa vie non
vous savez très bien de qui je veux
parler son mari sortie s'ils quittent le
monsieur qui était là tout à l'heure
c'est idiot d'euros ce drôle seuil alors
tu crois que je suis l'amant de sa femme
c'est une trouvaille que c'est amusant
merci mais alors tu d'adam pas compris
tout de suite compris quoi elle n'a pas
compris la pauvre chérie elle n'a pas
compris non mais dites moi est ce que
vous êtes en train de nous jouer une
comédie une comédie mais justement je ne
peux tu y est une comédie c'est une
comédie que nous répétons pour le cercle
parce que l'homme que tu as vu tout à
l'heure ça vu mais j'ai un nom il
s'appelle pas sa vie mais voilà ce
qu'ils trouvent
il s'appelle bas niveau oui c'est un
membre de mon cercle est dans la pièce
il fait le rôle de sabine est le mari
trompé et moi je fais la main je ne
voulais pas mais le président dadis ici
il n'ya que vous qui payez du physique
alors c'est toi lantinus du cercle ses
voiles antinoüs comme ça donne une fille
hérité de la potée des autres c'était
bien
chers amis c'était une pièce vraiment
oui mais ça en effet parfois j'avais
l'impression que c'était envers lui des
spas à mais tout le temps tout le temps
vers superbe vous aurez là gros succès
or il ya certaines scènes c'était bon
ben je crois bien que je croyais pas que
ça passerait si facilement la scène par
exemple où le mari reçoit de l'amant une
commande de konya au oui oui oui très
drôle mais c'est le clou ça nous y
comptons beaucoup
comment est ce déjà un quoi dallas la
série quoi dix mois les verts les verts
j'ai envie tu veux que je te dise les
belles ce n'est pas du tout fabriquer
des vers moi et bien voilà voilà
sa vie n'est s'avancer dit à part la
chose qui me dit lamenteront comme tu as
la mémoire des noms tous étaient
invérifiables qu'est ce que tu attends
je cherche je terminais tu comprend le
jeu cherche le film bad est versé
voilà alors sa vie n'est ce versant un
verre de cognac est vivant il est très
bon monsieur
votre excellent cognac mais il n'est pas
tous purent iliya de l'armagnac
n'est ce pas de cognac n'est pas trop
mal oui oui voilà voilà voilà
combien le payez vous moi mais vivre à
la bouteille samyn s c'est cher mais je
pourrais et qui vient de ma treille vous
fournira six francs une excellente fine
champagne
j'en ai justement encore deux ou trois
pièces à ma campagne
la licra jolie le dernier verre sur wii
n'est ce pas un oui il est long oui
c'est un verre je me reconnais pas moi
je fais des verts je sais pas
et quelle est ta réponse à à son offre
de cognac mais qu'est ce que tu voulais
je lui répondis je lui en ai pris en
asie dans didon sait pas faire ça un
suicide mais seulement je te donner
l'idée générale non mais c'est le jeu se
défaire oui oui alors si je veux du
cognac et par le jeu pourrait bien
expédié en tout de suite une pièce non
denses et poneys de qui est cette belle
pièce ça c'est ses droits ce temps chers
amis c'est de rostand l'a pas reconnu la
facture non partant c'est pourtant bien
reconnaissable
si c'était une pièce une pièce que vous
répétez battu pendant mes cannes a fait
on a éveillé l est et éveiller les
sacrements mais comment on a pu
travailler tout seul ça n'est jamais
arrivé
donc quelqu'un ce sera donc permis non
mon ami entre amis mais si tu savais ce
qui m'arrive ma femme ma femme qui a été
réveillé pendant mon absence non c'est
beau on ne fera jamais partie parce
qu'il ya un dieu la fenêtre ouverte est
passée par là qui sera rentré mais qui
quitte le polisson le doigt le son qui
m'a réveillé ma femme je voudrais tenir
comme ça te tiens des linges et rajsaman
mais je le rattrape et je te jure qui
passera même avec carnage le froid que
je trouve ça bien de retourner à batavia
à cause de lui ma femme a tout entendu
et que j'ai dû faire des verts a tu vois
d'ici ce que ça peut être des vrais mais
par un ingénieur
j'en avais trop court vient d'être
l'ambassade c'est une compensation alors
mais c'est égal on a bien raison de dire
que tout en a au fond de soi un poète
qui sommeille permet on n'a jamais dit a
peut être on a dit au coach on a tu
crois oui on savait bien que c'était
quelque chose comme ça je ne comprend
pas un mot de ce qu'ils me racontent ça
s'en souviendraient celle là monsieur à
thoiry la nuit vous mais qu'est ce que
je suis mais avant tout fait sortir
dessus votre fils mois vise à mon fils
le g km à ton mari que c'était ce que
vous me dites là qu'est ce qu'il a donc
tout le temps faire des enfants puisque
ce n'est pas votre avis fait sortir ce
quelconque
oui veux tu ça doit être un t'as peur ça
il vient pour lui emprunter de l'argent
c'est quelconque et mathieu fait vite
qu'est ce que vous voulez ce que je veux
venez avec moi ou ça j'ai ma femme ne
vous remercie pas ce soir du pardon ce
soir c'est précis mais qu'est ce que
vous faites donc aux impôts parce que la
mienne d'or texan il fallait réveiller
un est sous influence dans surveillance
des semblables comme notre train pour
aller dans apprécié et dans une tenue ou
me permettrez de ne pas commander ses
tenues ou ce sera noir dans mon
affolement oui je leur ai trop regardé
et je les endormis et qu'est ce que vous
avez fait un tournoi comme cela ce que
j'ai fait je les regarde et puis j'ai
dit tiens c'est ma femme et je vous
demande pas ça on n'a pas essayé de
réveiller commence juste deux boîtiers
voilà une demi-heure que je lascoux sans
arriver aucun résultat alors je me suis
dit y'a du riz paddy le g10 ribadier
tout court parce que le pied par la rue
ils savent est égal allez venez rythme
allez vous en vous pouvez bien vous
réveillez vous même mais comme les plus
attendues par les cantons pour lui
prenons les mains et on souffle au
dessus prenons-les
j'ai décidé sur les mains douces et aux
1 faut-il soufflé chaud petit souffle
etc 3 plus bas dont il allait rapatrier
faute et souple et chaud faute essoufflé
points mais chaud froid ça fait rien
mais ça mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette saison tri ou la dengue ils ont
pas moi j'ai rien entendu à ça tu sors
non tu sens où vas-tu journée mais
attend le cercle mon ami demain des
comores etienne 2 bonne place de tapas
porta représentation à lomé mais voyons
n'est pas question d'amener les femmes
ne sont pas admises à la présentation
assadi moi ton est ce que ça va durer
encore longtemps cette comédie que tu me
voue depuis une heure les crois tu donc
ogier penser que j'y ai cru une seconde
est que je ne sais pas ce que tu viens
chez sa maîtresse
moi oui toi à ton donné des maîtresses
mois est d'abord puisque c'est comme ça
dès ce soir tout le monde saura que tuer
l'amant de madame céline est malheureux
suffira pas ça a même généré elle-même
faire tout le temps des choses aux
conséquences
sa vie ne vous tuera sa femme en sera
quitte pour prendre un autre à mort
voilà sinon mes objectifs sera pas
atteint
c'est ce que nous ne manquera pas ça tu
ne le fais pas tu ne le feras pas
comment tu resterais ici tu alors bon je
vais endormi soins vouloir
en battant puisque ça y est je vais il
avait chez dormir comme ça à 10 ans 15
ans et son chapeau et son parapluie
elle rate et ouvrira ses portes la halle
et seulement elle va beaucoup me
dérangeait nous annonçons l'arrangement
là où dans une chambre en main non non
c'est pas possible c'est pas une
solution savez le camp de sortir de là
maintenant on dit de tubes litois là
dedans
ok l'idée avance ici toi web
or ta femme tire de wiki assieds toi là
à cette table nous allons faire une
partie des cartes et à cette heure ci à
propos de quoi vivre le fouille a pas de
temps à perdre il ne s'est pas jouée non
mais ça fait bien six mois qu'ils
gagneraient mais d'abord de songeons à
tous mais que fais tu là je la
déshabille devant moi oui je range ses
objets vous êtes reconduit si j'y
comprend quelque chose mais tu n'as donc
pas deviner que marc fans c'est tout bas
et qu'il n'y a que son moyen de conjurer
le mal faisons partie des quartiers n
ont qu une partie des cartes et et
comment tu ne saisis pas vu qu'il s'agit
de jouer ma femme elle écarté abalo ou
bakar a plongé de la benne dans un même
comprendre de jouer enfin nous allons
jouer marange nous nous allons lui
donner le sont je crois un coup on ira
bon oui c'est ça m'étonnait aussi de sa
part je te demande qu'une chose en tout
ça c'est de dire tout le temps comme moi
de dire tout le temps comme toi tu vois
pas très bien tout ça va nous mener au
feu je fais les cartes
je fais les cartes non c'est moi non
c'est moi
comme tu voudras comme tu voudras enfin
il faudrait se décider enfin il faudrait
se décider
c'est une tablette aux fidji de répéter
toutes mes paroles comment c'est toi qui
m'a dit de dire comme toi que tu avais
peut être de dire quoi moi d'abonder
dans mon sens quand ma femme sera
réveillé un bourg n'est ce pas parce que
je croyais maman mais allons aussi mais
ce n'est pas lui c'est pas y jouer oui
puis
oui c'est leur or moi j'en ai deux mais
tais toi ton mec est là vous suis-je
qu'est ce qui s'est passé e j mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait il joue aux cartes
avec tout mon coeur à tous qu'est ce que
ça veut dire et à tout ça fait ceinturer
gagner à quoi voit tout ça tu as bien
dormi chez renée comment j'ai bien dormi
ah oui je te demande qu'on voit là une
heure que tu fais un somme que je t'aime
moi non mais compris y compris mais ça
me va comme j'ai pris une veste
non mon en tout cas non chapeau voix
qu'est ce que j'ai fait de mon surpoids
une mine en tout cas comment est-ce que
tu les avais au un toupet je ne les
avais pas madame pourtant meilleur jeu
de voix voyons voyons voyons voyons ça
prend ça prend je ne suis pas folle pour
tancer voyons le tedx dis-moi tu n'es
pas sortis de terre
comment mois mamadou toto - n'ont pas
cessé de jouer les cartes et même il a
triché tout le temps à nommer père meurt
sur la vraisemblance
mais il n'est pas venu un homme ici non
oui monsieur savinet sa vie n'est nommé
tu connais sa vie n'est toi sa ville et
ses idées attends attends je crois me
rappeler que sous louis 11
un cousin de jeunes dames le mari de la
maîtresse de
faute de main mais très droite pedro
j'avais ma maîtresse tu entends le sa
maîtresse
alors forcément savait pas vrai il a
nommé le monde assure n'être pas de
porte
imprimé et coûte alors si vraiment ça
n'est pas vrai tu n'imagines pas leur
évite d'y odette que j'ai faits dont il
a rêvé toute ma femme en dv on gêne tu
avais une maîtresse mais attendez vous
avez vous ne savez même pas ce que je
vais dire son mari vous avez surpris
il s'appelait sabine et cet avis ne
céderont pas mauvais
mamadou bah d'eau va alors qu'ils
venaient de partir pour aller chez tam
et oui oui et alors
alors ça je ne veux pas raconter ça
dépend des cieux pourquoi il fait ça si
vous croyez que devant moi c'est un
reste vous n'avez pas mais je ne manque
pas je ne demande pas je ne raconterai à
mon mari quand nous serons tous là là là
là là c'était car j'avais bien cru que
c'était oui c'est idiot n'est ce pas
attendre eux ces visions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
a gelé par et des scandales à son nom
mais c'est ce qu'on espère ici alors
question en effet soufflé chaud froid
qui est le mari de la maîtresse de mon
arrivée il vise à dijon mais aller au
diamant je vais t'expliquer on est chez
moi monsieur
tout est fini entre nous ce que vous
avez dit que c'est y répondre
j'en ferai
[Applaudissements]
alors mon pauvre vieux tu te bats ah oui
mon cher et quel duel annuel où je dois
faire tous les ans est rentrée dont vous
êtes chez vous non bafana et coûte moins
cher je me fais pas d'illusions on ne
sait ni qui vit ni qui meurent j'espère
pourtant que ça se terminera bien on ne
sait jamais merci cependant l'illusion
ne devait pas se réaliser et bien prend
cette lettre elle contient mai dernier à
volonté aux hôtes et dernières volontés
nous avons bien c'est pénible décrire
ces choses là surtout quand il s'agit de
soi eh bien la voilà j'ai pensé à toi à
moi cette île possible oui pour la
remettre à ma femme dans le cas où
l'éventualité que nous appréhendons se
produira bon ça m'étonnait aussi de sa
part alors puis je comptais sur toi n'ai
pas peur pas plus tard que de mal les
aura
pas plus tard que demain c'est tout ce
que tu vas me dire non non voici encore
une lettre encore rennes il prend pour
le fact une lettre pour le président de
mon cercle c'est lui qui sera mon second
témoin ah oui il est un peu gâteux mais
enfin qu'est ce que tu veux il est
président alors plein de faire plaisir
allez prouver que oui mais si les gars
te bien vous vous entendrez tous les
deux pour ce qu'il y à faire je vous
confie mes intérêts c'est entendu ji
pour pour le reste à la craste tu me oui
mais oui mais bien la grâce de dieu
asahi siffleur voilà un témoin qu'une
façon de comprendre sa mission sophie
monsieur n'est pas encore venu de
messieurs on rare pour me demander
ah si monsieur et du charbonnier c'est
pas ça j'attends de messieurs de témoins
monsieur mari quelques noms se fit ma
pauvre sophie ce sont les témoins de mon
adversaire je peux pas monsieur parce
que c'est drôle
la partie y ait de quoi rire mais je ne
vois pas me citer c'est pas ce qui
manque pas de me voir si ces messieurs
venaient amené moi c'est curieux comme
tout le monde prend game en partie de
mon duel ça fait toujours rire on entend
dire il va se battre
ca cib est monsieur n'est pas encore
sorti de sa chambre à si madame madame
veut tel que j'aï le prévenir une
annonce sur tout à l'époque pré va bien
madame non mais c'est curieux ils m'ont
toujours là après l'autre et c'est à qui
ne se verra pas certes ne veux pas me
voir c'est il a coûté moquer de moi
c'est indigne c'est un pays aux profiter
des cours instant où sa femme d'or pur
c'est un petit et voilà voilà où nous en
sommes nous autres obligé de ne pas
dormir pour assurer notre repos à cet
égard c'était bien mais il ya quelque
chose de pas clair dans tout ça monsieur
saguenay si monsieur votre entrée voici
toujours madame madame je vous salue
pour m'en fous ici monsieur après ce qui
s'est passé madame je comprends que ma
présence et de quoi vous étonner je sais
qu'il est de règle en matière de duels
de ne communiquer avec son adversaire
que par l'entremise de ce témoin mais
les bleus je ne sais pas qui les a fait
en tout cas on ne m'a pas consulté par
conséquent je les en jean et le je tiens
à parler précisément monsieur ribadier
avant pelo témoins respectifs de sa
bouche
j'avais c'est bien simple je puis vous
dire à vous même
en deux mots voilà ce qu'ils valent
j'avais surpris n'est ce pas monsieur
rival des schémas fanal nous oui ça ne
pas vous qui devriez dire sam adams et
ma femme elle ne l'a pas dit ce qui est
fait est fait il n'y a pas à revenir en
arrière c'est un fait bien été j'avais
agi envers monsieur ribéry ont perfé
galantin je lui avais demandé qu'une
seule chose garder le secret et le pas
renouveler autant que possible
enfin ne pas renouveler qu'elle a tort
c'est de la générosité n'est il ne l'a
pas fait mais maintenant que des tiers
sont mêlés à cette aventure qui aurait
dû rester entre nous j'estime qu'une
rencontre est devenue inévitable ceci
naturellement pour ceux qui savent
parfois pour ceux qui ne savent pas je
préférerais pas ébruiter la faire oui je
serai très vexé de me singularise et à
bercy
vous êtes maman foulée j'aime autant
madame ne pas me faire remarquer c'est
pourquoi je viens demander à ce brave
ribadier de laisser ignorer à noter - ya
tout le monde
le véritable motif de l'autre rencontre
nous nous battons pour un prétexte
quelconque comme celui ci par exemple
que j'ai imaginé nous avons dîné
ribadier mois ensemble on a servi un vin
fin rivasi a dit que c'était du bordeaux
j'ai dit que c'était du bourgogne
c'était moi qui ai raison du nouvel an à
mort vous croyez que cette raison madame
nous n'entrerons pas de meilleur à bercy
une question professionnelle monsieur
tout ceci est à refaire entre vous et
monsieur ribadier quant à moi je n'ai
plus rien de commun avec qui comment
vous êtes fâché avec lui le mot était
mal on n'avait pas de philosophie on
vous en avait pas mais l'eau est ce que
vous croyez que dans le premier moment
j'en ai pris comme ça mon parti me non
un homme jeté comme vous qui était
ennuyé
mais voyez vous dans la vie le tout est
de bien établir sa situation à 6 ce
matin quand j'ai vu mon domestique
m'apporter mon déjeuner comme
d'ordinaire quand j'ai vu le concierge
m'apporter l'ailette je me suis dit
enseigne ariane changeait rien une
fiction
il ya beaucoup de conventions là dedans
vous preniez aussi en am dam de l'est de
notre côté donc mais je commence à vous
dire que je ne suis pas superstitieux
mais enfin peu de mains ce curieux une
affaire une affaire superbe après
laquelle je courais depuis deux mois
sans arriver à trouver une solution
et bien ce matin blanc de temps a gelé
conclu c'est moi qui la fourniture des
vins de bordeaux dans les boyaux duval
une affaire énorme ça ne veut rien dire
mais tout de même je serai en droit de
me dire et et syrie bad il n'était pas
venu me faire
est ce que j'aurai la fourniture des
vins de bordeaux dans les brouillons du
match 1
allons monsieur je vois que c'est vous
qui êtes l'obligé le monsieur ribadier
je n'aurais pas jusqu'à dire ça madame
je n'oublie pas sa conduite à mon égard
si encore il s'était contenté de me
prendre ma femme mais il ne parlait même
pas deux mois respectueusement nous nous
tenons tous nous faut que ça mais c'est
une lettre de votre mari à ma femme je
les avais baba en fouillant dans les
fait marrer c'est un abri hâtif de
thérèse ma femme s'appelle moi je
l'appelais d'été j'avais pris la
première syllabe lui il a pris ce qui
reste dans donnerait cantonnerait mois
des rires et la petit retard madame nous
a pas attendu pour ça m'arrivait je
viens de te quitter et j'éprouve le
besoin de tes cris j'ai été bien heureux
ce soir à nancy c'était quand mais at il
dit je savais bien que tu ne pouvais pas
aimer ton mari il a t-il au nom lisez
mal à manger que ce soit vous que moi je
savais bien que je ne pouvais pas aimer
ton mari il est comme un savant il
s'agit quoi vous trouvez ça poli qu'il
est heureux cet homme de vivre auprès de
toi tu es la femme à doha toujours de
combat à la mienne qui est insupportable
défiant génial attendez c'est pas fini
quels obstacles ce serait entre nous
sans mon précieux système comme c'est
commode
chaque fois que ton alors bon je vois
bien sur l'eau chaque fois que nous
avons m'adapter
comme c'est commode chaque fois que ton
à des cils de marines absente mais c'est
toujours moi vous trouvez abolie pour
avoir la clé des champs je n'ai qu'à
regarder ma femme d'une certaine façon
dans les yeux et la faune a endormi pour
autant de temps que nous en avons besoin
je m'endormais aussi la vieillesse moi
je comprends maintenant ses sommeils
d'inexplicable les menaces de visualiser
pas rien de la sorte peut troubler nos
amours aussi vous savez comme je t'aime
je t'aime bien pour que vous mettiez à
la sienne
comment ferait tout ça tout ça est hors
de question monsieur météo est en tout
cas je garde cette lettre elle pourra me
dire ah oui pardon je la garde aussi
pour la même raison aux mais ferme était
en effet quitte pas mon mari stingel
droite oui mais elle est écrite à ma
femme et comme telle elle n'appartient à
l'eau chacun l'a lui-même la feuille
blanche
alala faire ils m'ont donné dans cette
pièce qui aurait pu me dire que j'étais
dans le pathos et enrobés mais
maintenant je sais ce qui m'attend
j'irai vivre toutes celles aussi amateur
moshi moshi je dis mon mari me rendre à
ma tête parce que vous voyez que aubade
arabe où l'on sait bien qu'il va pas la
garde des sceaux ne nous séparons assez
juste diable diable diable là qu'est ce
que ça peut vous faire
enfin pour votre mari ça ne me fait rien
mais c'est pour moi je dis diable diable
diable là pourquoi mais parce que la dot
évidemment il faut la rendre régulation
rester mais comment femme n'a apporté
ses 410 fond moi je les ai converti en
valeur argentine
et bien ce moment là c'était très bien
maintenant ça vaut même pas le quart
annonce je peux pas à vendre dans ma
poche je suis incapable de lui restituer
sa d'auto vous avez votre sortie une
personne elle est représentée par maison
vous en parlez à votre aise alors parce
qu'il a plu monsieur ribadier la france
2 et qui m'ont fait d'efforts et ça me
coûtait de l'argent je vais encore
l'être mais la leur
je n'ai pas jeté façon vous a fait
j'allais voir ténu de type n'était pas
feinte pour mon avis oui répond lui qui
était pour moi et je veux dire att avait
lui vendu une bonne explication et vous
direz à cet excellent riri ribadier que
je suis désolé mais j'ai pas eu le temps
de latence fait ici je me suis vous
plaît et il faudra que ma femme me donne
de bonnes raisons non les foires jean
teintait à 347 ce matin ça je ne peux
pas vendre à ce prix
alors un ami qui arrive quand elle te
donnera de bonnes raisons et même s'ils
ne sont pas roms tu t'arranges rats pour
les trouver tel après voilà les hommes
tenez heureusement qu'ils ne sont pas
comme ça nous autres thann et monsieur
ribadier pourrait bien me donner toutes
les bonnes raisons qu'il voudra mais
c'est un autre n'est-ce pas là la
rejette
alors on lit mobile ici on la mélange un
coin à nous de mon bonhomme ça je veux
que votre belle idée tourne à votre
confusion et je vais voter
ma femme pardon madame on m'avait dit
que monsieur m'attendais d'ici comme
monsieur ne parlons pas de la personne
qui était ici il n'a pas pu vous
attendrai les parties de gm vous parlait
quant à moi oui c'est une chose des plus
graves
bon ben je sais tout ce que vous pouvez
me dire je connais tous mes torts vous
pourrez donc demandé le divorce contre
moi hélas non monsieur nous ne pouvons
pas divorcer quel que soit le désir que
j'en ai il s'est passé ici des choses si
grave que je ne dois pas divorcer que
dites vous il est bien vrai n'est ce pas
que chaque soir vous avez besoin de
votre liberté vous m'endormir et comment
vous mais je ne chercherai pas à mentir
c'est vrai il avoue eh bien monsieur
tous les soirs chaque fois que vous
étiez parti et que j'étais endormi un
homme pénétrer dans ce salon
que dis tu es alors abusant de mon état
et profitant de l'obscurité non mais
c'est faux dit moi que c'est faux las
elle le voudrait non mais je comprends
alors hier soir la fenêtre ouverte
non non mais c'est pas possible mais
qu'allait-il cette âme son nom sa ligne
non mais tu le reconnaîtras enfin tu
l'as vu un débat n'ont jamais journal 1
pt toujours baisser au nom mais tous les
soirs alors un homme et qui sait en
sommes il s'était peut-être plusieurs de
nos acheteurs et pompes c'était toujours
la volonté 3 4 étoiles mais bon gars
mais ce n'est pas ma faute vous m'aviez
audomarois y ont été appelés du décrié
les criaient on écrit que dans les
pauvres c'est à dire que c'était un coup
alors merci marc machin qu'est ce que tu
veux moi comment moi allons dont tous
les soirs tu sais bien que noah l'on
doit tu n'as pas besoin de te défendre
je sais bien qu avec moi on est
parcimonieux chez soi quand on est pro
dit qu'avec ces propos on t'offre pas tu
sais où on ne peut pas être à la fois
ministre de l'intérieur et des affaires
étrangères au travail
enfin monsieur voici l'horrible vérité
et upa biens virtuels et on devait preah
vihear et on tient les soit j'ai besoin
d'être seul de réfléchir de comprendre
non mais je le trouverai une misérable
salaire tu seras bien malin si tu lui
arrive c'est affreux ce qui m'arrive
c'est pas ben voilà ce que tu as faim un
pays cible
voilà ce dont tu es la course avec tes
désillusion n'est pas coupable la pauvre
martyrs c'est toi à toi ô dieu te
conduire comme tu devais au lieu de
trouver ta femme comme font tous les
maris avec des moyens classiques
tu as voulu faire le savant avoir
consistait matches où tu mènes le
système ribadier arrive de séton
président il ne peut pas les morts par
conséquent pour tomber en bas il s'agit
également
un autre chose en tête que mon de m
c'est le rêve
ma femme ne voulait pas de raconter
devant toi s'apprécient et bien el
massoudi a vraiment été un bon match
mais oui
imagine toi que tous les soirs quand
j'étais chez ma famille n'est en inconnu
s'introduisent est ici non non non non
non tous les soirs mon ami oh non pas
tous les soirs qui tous les soirs mais
sinon c'était pas moi je sais bien que
c'était pas toi tu as cru que je te
disais ça parce que je soupçonnais mais
non non seulement tu mais qu'est ce que
tu me dis là est un peu misérable qui
s'introduisait oui et profiter lâchement
du sommeil dans la semaine ne servent
pas j'ai peur de comprendre tu viens on
gère ta femme madame ribadier tous les
soirs
tum annonce ça sans ménagement comme ça
à moi mais tu vois ma tête ici quand
j'ai appris
mais ta tête à tête tu penses qu'à ta
tête tu toi sa vie c'est grave qu'elle
ait dit maintenant connus faux nom
puisque c'est un inconnu jusque là
connue et une soupçonne personne quoi
personne tout le monde c'est tout le
monde qui est l'âme en danger l'ariège
de l'île résultats du système néolibéral
misérable dire qu ils s'introduisaient
tous les soirs par cette fenêtre au est
accrochée 10-10 une boucle de gilet avec
un morceau de pâte arraché tout le
décide et non c'est pas moi elle est
jaune un mail railleries mal acquis à
qui il voue claude gillet tous les ans
portent des gilets ça ne m'a dit que
rien sat indique toujours que c'est un
homme dont les passages m'en doutais
mais annoncer la moitié du genre humain
un homme la moitié du genre humain pour
une femme seule au c'est à ce passé la
tête mais c'est moi monsieur qui va les
prendre les ordres tour et les ja pas
d'or allez au nom aller au wat la boucle
lui son gilet est un plus qu'est ce
qu'ils sont le cocher misérable vieux
moi vous voulez me sortir monsieur non
mais vous resterez vous c'est à vous que
je parle ces messieurs
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont me faire un six
sept roms là le supporter de voeux qu'il
est là le voilà me voilà qu'est ce
qu'ils ont à me dévisager ma carte bleue
ils sourient ils à leur audace de
sourire je reste ou non il faut savoir
l'interroger sans avoir les oui il
s'agit d'être diplomate l'essm affaires
d'été consulat batave dire ça
approchez-vous à s'accrocher ne
seriez-vous pas par hasard le séducteur
de madame non mais je dis terre non
c'est ça que tu appelles de la
diplomatie fait très fort vous allez
être pris jamais tu es toi laisse moi
faire approcher connaissez la boucle non
gillet sa boucle à recoller c'est ça
tout genre mais oui en bien j'ai cherché
raseta boucle à greding c'est toi laisse
paquita produisait tous les soirs quand
le c3 et quand je n'étais pas là
monsieur s'est tournée pour une femme un
tu venais pour une femme allons à vous
monsieur la galanterie je suis un
gentleman 53 pour toi c'est bien alors
c'est toi qui venaient tous les soirs
ici dans l'obscurité
c'était moi tu avais bien soin de ne pas
relever la lampe j'allais aussi bien ton
show est plus arrosée là pour ouvrir 100
par la violence en dehors de sa volonté
mois jeudi par un violent dont c'est
elle qui me faisaient des avants aux
familles bac l affaire pour une bonne
c'est elle qui lui a fait des avances
enfin elle a toujours eu un faible pour
écho chez mais jugez vous la misérable
tient vatan par là et attend que je vais
te chercher mes enfants comptait 50
pointu mais tu voudras parcours bois qui
n'ont fait que vale part à mon ami mon
avis c'est à pois c'est monstrueux à la
sainte nitouche qui aurait pu se douter
quand elle veut jouer la comédie 1 1
avec lille qui sont cochées ce serait un
homme bien encore eh oui mais quand on
lui propose un homme bien ne veut pas
avec mon coach et un subalterne mon ami
ça fait mal dans ta bouche je sais pas
voir angèle rochelle il ya des
situations qu'il faut savoir prévoir
dans la vie mais lasses degré là non
approché madame je sais tout savons tout
madame tout quoi ce qui se passait ici
l'inconnu tous les soirs
bien sûr ce graffiti dit oui mais ce que
vous m'aviez pas dit c'est que vous le
connaissiez l'inconnu et que nous le
connaissons également pas vraiment
laissé mes couplets nous a tous dit
voilà vous entendez tout tout et ce
n'est pas lui qui abusaient de votre
sommeil c'est vous qui a lié le chercher
auront-ils hélas mal à votre amant il
est là mené le le voilà en très forte le
cocher il a tout avoué
vous oui madame c'est tout avoué j'avoue
encore devant vous mais c'est faux
commencez tôt mais tu ne le crois pas
n'est ce pas je ne veux pas que tu fais
quoi maintenant voyons jamais jamais
donc je savais que c'était une invention
je voulais que tu le coi a pas de te
faire subir le sentiment de tout ce que
tu m'as fait souffrir mais dès l'instant
où par une raison que je ne comprends
pas du tout tu peut sérieusement
imaginer vous mais non je te le jure
mais je la mets moi avec le coach mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire où allez-vous
moi ça quelle est cette femme qui est
sophie monsieur la femme de chambre
mekkid on avait beau cru mais personne
c'était sophie données guzman je vous
dois 50 francs voilà de louis vous
garder leurs excès mais ça fait pas pour
nous mais c'est bien ce n'est pas la
peine d'en parler je la trouve une
mauvaise je rattraperai s'assure lavoine
gel que c'est mal à toi de t'être ainsi
jouer de moi que tu m'aimes toujours le
sait bien c'est bien monsieur je ne
regrette qu'une chose c'est que vous
n'ayez pas souffert encore d'un portable
mais tout est fini entre nous et eux
n'ont rien et cuit du tube get to et la
preuve c'est que je veux prendre à 10
heures
et quand je crois à la vôtre as tu me
rends ma liberté très bien je vais de ce
pas chez madame sa vie n'a cette fois
pas sarah tu vois bien aux jeunes que je
suis fait mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
moque-t-on
non moi au moins promets moi une chose
que tu ne retournera plus jamais chez
cette femme ont niché elle dit chez
d'autres angèle je donne ma démission
des affaires étrangères dorénavant je
reste tout à l'intérieur
[Musique]
je crois que je ferai aussi bien de
retourner à batavia
[Applaudissements]
yes et nous avons eu la joie
d'interpréter devant vous et de georges
feydeau et maurice ncaa les costumes
de donald cardwell
avec l'interprétation suivante genre
qu'elle
alain fredo
[Applaudissements]
virginie pradal
valleyfield hébert
[Applaudissements]
et simone renom
la prise en scène et de robert mallet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]